larry walker in his 10 years in a
colorado uniform hit 334
258 home runs
848 rbis and the numbers go on and on
the national league mvp in 1997
when he led the league with 49 homers
hit
366
130 rbis 50 other extra base hits and 33
stolen bases
he had
six gold gloves in his career
and a five-time all-star
no doubt larry walker
was a great colorado rocky and most
deserving of being in the hall of fame
in cooper's town john gray gets the call
start number 28 for the rockies 8-11
4.17 earned run average 140 in a third
innings 128 hits now here's brandon bell
who hit his 27th home run of the year
last night
it was a pitch up above the strike zone
now he swings and he crushes one deep
right field and that one is gone into
the lower deck
brandon belt who has had a lot of
success over the years against gray
has still more and the giants have a
one-nothing lead
the 28th home run for belt who leads the
club in that category anthony
getting the start for the giants it'll
be his 30th of the season 12 wins seven
losses 3.23 era cj crone is the hitter
ground ball towards third the only play
for flores is to first rogers scores
and the game is tied at one on the rbi
ground out by cj crone charlie blackmon
moves to second ryan not in the starting
lineup last night made it out as a pinch
hitter
3-2 pitch
get pretty well to left field dickerson
on the run won't catch up to it it'll
one hop the wall
blackman scores ryan mcmahon with an rbi
double
the rockies take the lead two to one so
now mcmahon at second two runs in here
is elias diaz
right-handed bat and catcher who's hit
18 home runs this year
he's stefani throws and a hanging slider
is ripped to left field but backing up
in on the ball as dickerson reaches up
and makes it the catch as he got near
the warning tread that one just kept on
going
as it will often do at altitude flores
the guy at the plate has tied his career
high
in homer's
and strike three called on the outside
corner with a slider
flores was headed towards first and
jim wolfe said nope the dugout's in the
other direction so two down in the
inning and here comes john gray
dee stefani quickly back to him struck
him out swinging
that's the quick inning a 10 kitchen
stephen duggar the center fielder
left hand batter will be the first one
to face gray gray with the look in has
that sign and the pitch to duggar swing
and a miss got him on a slider and john
gray has strikeout number two good pitch
by john gray back to the plate o2 pitch
swaying and a miss got d sclafani on
three pitches
and that is the third strikeout for john
gray second here in the third inning
rhino tapia leads off against dee
stefani
he grounded out to short his first time
d stefani throws and he struck him out
swinging with a hard slider in under the
hands
one out for lamont wade the right
fielder
2-2
in a cold strike three
and it'll be alex dickerson's turn
to see what he can do
gray holding that ball behind his right
leg as he stares in
dickerson readies in the left-hand box
now gray puts his glove at the belt
there go the runners 3-2 pitch is a
dribbler to the right side taken by cj
crone races to the bag three steps and
that'll do it for the giants in the
fourth third time through now tommy
lestella
oh good pitch by gray
so john on a hard biting slider gets the
stella for the first out in the fifth
so here's belt belt is homered and he's
rolled out to first
a two ball one strike count the infield
backed up normal depth
that one is hit high and deep to right
field a soaring shot
second deck
goodbye and the giants have gone ahead
four to two
brandon belt now that
was a thing of beauty
number 29 for brandon belt
now cj crone will come up and he's the
man he's
the big
home run
and rbi man the run producer for the
rockies this year
he began the day
tied for
the league lead in rbi it's going back
to august the third that's when he
really got hot
he came into this game tonight since
that date hitting 442 at coors field
and the pitch
and a slider on the inside popped up
foul first base side and it's it's still
fair belt goes over right behind the bag
and stops and makes the catch in
fairground and the inning is over
great pitch there by rogers to get the
slugger
the inning is over and we head to the
eighth with wade crawford and flores do
up giants four
rocky's two so here comes duggar a ball
of a strike
sheffield again ready throws
there's a swing and a liner into shallow
left center field that's going to get
down base head
crawford will come in to score
and everybody else will move up one base
steven duggar
knocks in the run and the giants have a
five to two lead and with jastremski
entered in as the pinchhitter
and kinley's 3-2 pitch on the way
swinging yes lines one in the right
center field that's going to get down
face it
flores will come in to score rounding
third heading home is dickerson and he
scores
and going to third is duggar
yostremski delivers and the clutch it is
seven to two giants
but here comes more trouble
brandon belt
and belt's going to hit it into short
right field mcmahon's got it throw to
first and they get brandon bell
ryan mcmahon
keeps belt from having a four hit night
and another rbi
so two down
the base is loaded and here is krone
full count
to krone
the giants ahead 7-2
here's the stretch by leone there go the
runners the pitch
swing of the ground ball to third
backhanded by longoria the long throw to
first
in time and the ball game is over
you